California representative Adam Schiff
ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee has led efforts
in Congress to block the release of the
memo on surveillance he's with us from
Fort Lauderdale for an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning congressman
thank you this is Beth the Speaker of
the House Paul Ryan said yesterday that
this memo is not an indictment of the
FBI and then the president tweeted this
morning that it is what do you make of
that well unfortunately in this case
it's clear from the president that this
is exactly the purpose behind this
cherry-picking of information that Devan
hoon has wants to release this is
designed to impugn the credibility of
the FBI to undermine the investigation
to give the presidential fodder to
attack the investigation and it's a
tremendous disservice to the American
people who are going to be misled by
this by the selective use of classified
information and more than that it's a
terrible new line that we've crossed
where we're going to decide okay we're
going to take this classified
information and make it public but we're
going to hide this constant information
that's about information so that people
can be misled I think it's a really
dishonest thing to do and people in
Congress that support this are gonna be
held to account congressman what about
the central claim the Republicans make
which is that this dossier which was
funded by the Democrats was used to get
the warrant to look into Carter Page who
was part of the Trump campaign so that
you have essentially an investigation
here that comes from a partisan document
well unfortunately until this is
released I can't comment on the
underlying documents but I can't say
among the changes that I thought were
notable that the chairman made after the
release was approved by our committee
but before was sent to the White House
is a reference to omissions that were
called significant emissions removed the
word significant so it may be the
position now of at least the Chairman
that what was claimed to be significant
omissions are no longer significant but
the reality is there is no demonstration
in this memo in this misleading memo of
a systemic abuse that the FBI has as has
been posited by the president and his
allies
and instead the majority in the interest
of transparency only wants certain facts
to be seen and is thus far refused to
allow the Democratic response to be seen
but just to be clear since you're a
former federal prosecutor as well the
allegation that's being made by the
Republicans that someone within the FBI
or Justice Department could essentially
trick or fool a federal judge at FISA to
issue a warrant for surveillance is that
profound ignorance about how this whole
process works aren't there more checks
and balances in place there are a lot of
checks and balances in place and what's
more that's a gross mischaracterization
of what has happened here and that is
just an effort to undermine the FBI to
do the president's bidding there's no
evidence of a corrupt effort to obtain
warrants against people in the Trump
campaign that's been the president's
narrative but there's no evidence of
that and instead what will be released
by the president over the objections of
the FBI which is called the document
quite rightly misleading and inaccurate
is is an effort to undermine the Russian
investigation don't look at what the
Russians did don't look at what the
Trump campaign did in combination with
the Russians just put the government on
trial and Congressman what we need to be
thinking about the long-term damage done
to these institutions okay what is his
status congressman of the Democratic
response well we're gonna try to force
another vote on this the Republicans
voted down the release of the Democratic
response which was quite breathtaking
because they said they were offering
their own memo and interest of full
transparency I don't think that position
can be sustained I think they're gonna
have to release our memo but what they
wanted to do was have this misleading
document sit out there for at least a
week slow-walk the Democratic response
so they could hopefully make this the
narrative again it's just playing
partisan politics with classified
information and it really breaks this
compact with the intelligence community
and law enforcement that we would treat
the information they share with us with
respect that we would not seek to abuse
it for partisan purposes and it will
mean in the future they're a lot less
willing to share information with us as
the FBI's credibility been damaged here
no but I think the the Chairman's
credibility has been damaged and the
fact that the president United States
will blithely disregard the admonitions
of both his own FBI director in the
Department of Justice tells you all you
need to know about where the president's
priorities are it's not protecting
classified information it's not
respecting the hard-working men and
women at the FBI it's whatever the
president deems to be in a short-term
political interest all right congressman
Schiff we'll have to leave it there more
to come for sure thank you very much